pick your favorite female celebrity just
pick one right she's had a yeast
infection it was the worst it was like I
felt like something was alive in there
just Joey Joey the discharge like that's
scary why as your team yes not like a
wedgie you know kind of get that out you
see it's itchy it's itchy itchy itchy
itchy I was in college so I was away
from home anything going on in that area
I didn't really have any knowledge about
and I paid the hospital a visit because
I thought that it was on fire when I got
it I was freaking out I thought it was
an STD I mean I was freaking out I was
going to my boyfriend's hometown to meet
his entire family I woke up and my
vagina was I can't even say it she cuz
it's so much more than that
and when the doctor was like okay he
came in he's like yeah you have a yeast
infection I just started crying like oh
no I was super nervous with the
conversation uh with you know the guy I
was like newly dating and I just said so
I have a yeast infection and it just
like came out then I could talk to his
mom like one of the first times I met
her about it which absolutely not and so
I went to my mom and she's like Marilyn
calm down it's just yeast infection like
everyone gets them I went to the doctors
and she's like oh you have yeast
infection she said get Monistat it's
fine thank goodness it did it did work
I'd give it about a day and if I'm still
itchy then I go I go to the drugstore
and get I get Monistat I give it about
an hour yeah and I was there
I always tried to do like something
natural and it never worked
let me just try this coconut oil first
let me put like grass
I'm actually pretty into home remedies
but when I woke up with this I wanted
medication so fast an East infection can
be cured so don't freak out it's gonna
be okay
it's the East infection don't worry you
just like the rest of it
[Music]